and look when it when it comes to you
know honors and and Boris Johnson Boris
Johnson asked me to do something that I
wasn't prepared to do because I didn't
think it was right
that was uh you know either overrule the
holak committee or to make promises with
people now I I wasn't prepared to do
that as I said I didn't think it was
right and if people don't like that then
tough
I um well I got this job
it when I when I got this job I said I
was going to do things differently
because I wanted to change politics and
that's what I'm doing and I'm also Keen
to make sure that we change how our
country works and that's what I'm here
talking about today making sure that we
can grow our economy that we can
maintain our leadership in the
Innovative industries of the future why
because it's going to create jobs for
people it's going to spread opportunity
around and it has the potential as we've
been discussing to transform people's
lives and as prime minister I want to
make sure that that happens because I
want to make sure that I improve
everyone's lives in this country and do
it in a way that is right and is in
accordance with my values and that's
what I'm going to keep doing